the migrants are attempting the journey
in unseaworthy boats
every day if the weather is good
most are rescued at sea pulled to safety
by the emergency services
or plucked from the dangerous tides by
the border force
this group from africa and the middle
east picked up early
amongst them women and very young
children
the crossing can take up to 10 hours
navigating the busiest shipping lane in
the world
with just hope and prayer these people
bedraggled and tired arrived further
down the coastline
trudging up the beach carrying what few
belongings they could take with them
what about you where are you from sir
they traveled thousands of miles to get
here
from asia africa and the middle east
this is now a familiar scene on the kent
coastline
this group arrived in the last half an
hour they were rescued in the channel by
the lifeboat service
they've been given food and water
and they're just having their names and
their details their country where they
came from
taken now by immigration officials
policing the channel is becoming
increasingly difficult
and a political nightmare for the
government it's promising to fix what is
described
as the broken asylum system but making
the crossing a criminal offence
will do nothing to stop people
attempting the dangerous journey
according to human rights groups the
only way to claim asylum in this country
is to physically get here
so we have to find a way that people can
do it without risking their lives in
dinghies
one way would be humanitarian visas
another way would be increasing the
numbers that come by resettlement routes
but i don't think the government wants
to do either of those things
they like people to feel that they're
being overrun and that is just
isn't the case the home office says
an additional 55 million has been handed
to the french to clamp down
but with hundreds of miles of beaches
and the criminal gangs becoming more
sophisticated
it is a game of cat and mouse with the
authorities on this side of the channel
warning the tide of migration
won't stop alex rossi sky news
kent